world premiering introducing for the
first time gym news new source on the
Internet the place where we talk about
things that happen on the internet topic
that are of interest News number one JK
Rowling is under the the fire lately
JK Rowling response to gay Dumbledore
controversy
JK Rowling the wonderful author who
didn't take a second before calling me
out publicly for being a fascist thank
you thank you JK basically what happened
was that JK Rowling the queen of after
thought after writing seven books she
she thought it would be nice that if
Dumbledore without any hint in any of
the seven books that Dumbledore one of
the main character was a homosexual and
nice little afterthought you know of
course and you know why because they're
no different that's why that's how
genius I am because there are no
different from normal people that's why
I don't even have to write it in I will
however take all the code the glory for
being for being so forward thinking you
are welcome so now that the new movies
are coming out with Dumbledore's pass or
a
his previous character as young it was
exposed that none of that will be shown
the route Dumbledore will in fact not be
displaying that he is in two boys and JK
Rowling sort of responded to people's
criticism about this people weren't too
happy kind of calling her out for her
hypocrisy that hey I thought you said
that he was a homosexual character then
why isn't he all the sudden and JK
responded with I'm gonna mute you that's
how you know someone responds well to
criticism when they she won't even
listen to it
JK Rowling which of course also so
progressively thought yes her money was
actually black as clearly evidence all
over her seven books displayed like here
and here here's the tragic case of me
actually agreeing with polygon fantastic
beefs sequel needs to show thumblr
sexuality not just hint at it you have
created a world with werewolf's wizards
and all kinds of [ __ ] I don't watch
Harry Potter or read the books but I
know there's you got magic in it but a
man publicly displaying that he his
sexuality that's too far thank that
cannot exist in this world thank you
very much it's like she wants the cake
and eat it too and people call her out
on it and she's a crybaby JK Rowling is
a lost billionaire woman who can't face
criticism nothing new here the next new
slogan Paul went skydiving and his main
parachute didn't open ah oh my god I
think that's the wrong emoji that they
used I should have used the that emoji
or perhaps many of you asked what my
opinion was to buy Logan Paul returning
to YouTube and it's pretty simple he
shouldn't she should be able to return
there shouldn't be any problems with it
and I personally I don't have any
problems with it I for one loved seeing
slow-mo shots of Logan Paul with a
serious face maybe petting his dog or
maybe just wrapping his fingers together
that's that's what I subscribe for Logan
Paul and I'm glad that he is back doing
what he's doing best yes touch the stone
ah can I just say I love his haircut
it's just perfect it just made me
completely forget about everything I
need a new heck I need a new that's
better I guess the thing about this
video is that local pulse initial video
that started all the drama it was made
to make himself look better in the eye
of suicide that's what he did he just
did it so miserably that it just
completely collapsed and at the end of
the day this video was doing the same
thing he's trying to make himself look
better in the eye of suicide there's
really no difference but the general
thing to learn here that it's okay to do
that it's okay to benefit from suicide
as long as you're doing it in the right
way one important note that I got from
the video was that he met up with this
gent that survived from jumping off the
Golden Gate Bridge which is obviously
doesn't happen and he was met with
instant regret and he uses that to speak
out against suicide and it's a good
isn't this a great story and it's great
that he's getting featured basically
when I was during my immediate storm
everyone told me to do this exact same
thing everyone told me you need to meet
with people you need to travel around
the world to interact and show people
that you've learned you need to appear
on interviews and I just personally felt
that that was very disingenuous it
seemed like I'm obviously just doing it
to repay my image or to repair my image
I'm not doing it out of pure good
intention which sort of spoils it
completely for me and I just thought
that would that's just disingenuous I
don't want to do that I would rather
just show people that I've changed
through my videos and time he also
didn't
interview with ABC with Michael Michael
I'm 22 years old I'm gonna be honest
with you Michael Michael I've gotten to
meet Michael so he's 100 yards away from
the park my it just it doesn't make any
sense and I believe it happened for a
reason
so apparently because it was just
hundred yards from the parking lot and
and Logan Paul found a dead body it
happened for a reason there's a divine
Logan Paul is on a divine path of
redemption
this all happened for a reason who would
have thought it would have happened no
one for parents out there because you're
the father thirteen year old twin girl
it's very hard to know everything that
your kids watch and there are a lot of
parents the parents we're not gonna pay
for your March anymore every parent I
meet whose kids are under the age of
like 12 I go hey you you let your kids
watch my stuff that's right parents
don't worry about everything that
happened it wasn't Logan Paul's fault it
was your fault okay you should not have
let your kids watch his videos what are
you stupid parents come on man what are
you doing parents obviously post-fall
when you put out content like that do
you realize the age of your audience
it's odd because Michael I'm 22 years
old it's not like I'm making content
necessarily for kids mm-hmm you 100%
they are making content for kids Logan
you know your demographic every youtuber
ever knows their demographics that
that's how you were successful it's in
your analytics and it's also you meet
them I I know people say well RP only
the young ones show up at events like
this and stuff like that but no I
when I did my meetups ever all the
people there too they were not there's
all kids in fact there were more young
teens and young adults than kids you're
lying you're just lying I try not to
live my life thinking about money
yeah
yeah I'm sorry what can you repeat that
please
I try not to live my life thinking about
money your whole channel is built about
money Logan it's the only thing that
draws us in these little kids to look up
to you oh look at all these flashy car
you have the mansion your whole brand is
built around it Logan are you kidding me
the twenty seventeen year review video
where do I begin I guess I could start
with this twenty two years old I bought
my first house for six point five
million dollars but it wasn't quite
satisfied so I had a koi pond foot in he
painted the walls of the guest house but
a giant truck known as the Yeti
a lot of school bus and then turned it
into a cool bus install the home theater
system more material objects guys the
point is I bought a lot of things
including this Rolex I try not to live
my life thinking about money like I said
look and Paul should just keep making
videos and be honest that's that would
be my advice and as long as he's not I'm
gonna call him out on it
now which brings back to this headline
Logan Paul went skydiving and his main
parachute didn't open he posted on
Twitter that you had to cut away his
main parachute because he didn't open
and he had to use the blue reserve
parachute remember the guy that jumped
off the bridge and survived
well now Logan Paul has someone that he
can relate to it normally I wouldn't
think better of people but seeing Logan
Paul's behavior and I think I'm someone
that can understand this sort of
mentality where you're just dishonest I
really truly think that he just jumped
with the second parachute
I would not accuse people of this [ __ ]
just that a super-special but seeing all
these track record of dishonesty and
doing literally anything to redeem your
brand I'm gonna call it out it seems too
perfect for me to see him talk to a guy
that jumped off the bridge and survived
and then this is gonna be his first vlog
right this is gonna be his comeback vlog
I haven't seen it hasn't come out yet
but I'm pretty sure this is gonna be his
vlog and now he gets a chance to feel
like yes you know I survived a jump now
I feel now I feel the same way and if
you think I'm crazy people are already
saying it maybe now you'll stop shame
suicide as a joke
first you have this video and this is
very specific big thing happens in
relationship to it obviously Logan knows
his next vlog is gonna have to be
important it's gonna have to have some
sort of message you can't just keep
making videos and move on I'm not
playing it I'm not buying it I know
people will think I'm crazy like I'm put
on a tinfoil hat or something I'm not
buying it I'm not buying it for a second
stop being dishonest Logan that's all
you have to do
next news few views that's right we have
more Susan Wojcicki tweeted CEO of
YouTube I think that's their position at
least that she's been listening closely
to your thoughts and ideas for the past
year so I wanted to share my priorities
for creators in 2018 it's a long blog
post going through basically
acknowledging the issues I would say she
sort of spices on some some good bits
here and there light like not everything
is bad hey they have super chat now and
in 2017
the number of creators making six
figures grew by 40% so it's not all bad
but she did recognize the demoness the
monetization in this message she says
but even as our platform continues to do
well around the world too many of you
Orton fortunately had to learn about it
new word in 2017 the monetization it's
nice to have it acknowledged at least it
would be nicer to see what is going to
be done I think I think a real good
course of action would be to stop
letting people have this guessing game
with YouTube you're gonna have to start
filling people in on what is going on
and why for example a video gets
demonetised whenever my video gets to
monetize I have to play this guessing
game of what costing what was it in this
10-minute video that that wasn't allowed
was it because I said Dorian at that
point was that too much you never know
it's so I wish they'd just say hey this
doesn't fit into our Community
Guidelines I can go okay I'll cut that
out not a problem and then I can move on
with my day and instead of having to
spend hours of reuploading reuploading
spending so much time and I think this
is a problem with most creators when I
when a clip gets claimed by another
company they take all the revenue of the
video so let's say I use audio from
someone that I didn't know was
copyrighted or something like that it's
hard to tell I know it's stupid you
shouldn't do it but sometimes it just
happens and they claim the video they
get all the revenue
and plus that if they don't even have to
say why they claimed it or what is
claimed there's still so many issues
with the system and they're making it
harder for creators to earn their
revenue that they deserve
you have really creative people really
making amazing stuff that don't get the
revenue just to give an example you have
this really creative mean video that I
reloaded because I wanted to react to it
it's a really great video probably took
[ __ ] ton of edit to put in and it's to
display the means of 2017 if I showed
this bit in my video the company that
owns this video can claim my video and
take all the revenue for this entire
video just because I showed it that's
enough to justify the claim there's so
many issues and I think that's what
needs to be addressed stop letting
youtubers have this guessing issue I do
think they are gonna make an effort and
I'm glad this is talked about from Susan
that right I hope that Susan makes more
statement like this I think it's great
and it gives some transparency and and
generally a direct reply to the
community we discussed today let me know
also make sure that you check out the
new merch now it comes in hoodie that's
right look like if you enjoyed it as
always squad for them every parent I
meet whose kids are under the age of
like 12 I go hey you you let your kids
watch my stuff
[Music]
[Applause]